foreign
where the hell have you been
oh no take your timers it's only our
entire lives on the line here
Ben didn't do it
what did you do with the panto
have you got it
how can you be sure he didn't because he
ended at BB okay that's how
you wouldn't do that for me I don't know
what I was thinking
I've ruined it all
us
okay if anyone in this room did it we
need to say
aminus
no one is gonna have to deal with this
alone we'll close rank Circle in
it's the only way we can all be
protected
Earth
she was on her own all night
to say she didn't because I didn't
because she didn't okay
so both of you can automatically believe
and I have to provide a bloody Alibi she
didn't have someone else involved she's
a psycho
I'm not the one who tried to kill
someone so my husband didn't discover my
Affair just stop okay just stop you're
the psycho where were you Becca I need
to know where you were that night why
was there mud on your shoes I got
hammered at the pub missed Marple I was
worried you would do something Reckless
so I got pissed you've taught me well
don't talk to her like that what are you
fighting about
um nothing just politics
ever since John Paul died whenever I
walk into the room you stop talking no
we don't what's happened Grace you okay
they did a postmortem on John Paul my
signature is on this like I agreed to it
it's dirty bastards shut up
oh my God
you knew about it
you knew about the postmortem
why did they exhume John Paul's body
oh
because they think he was murdered
[Music]
and I think it was one of us who did it
one of you
why would they think that
because they think we all had reason to
kill him
and no just stop lying to her
because we may not have killed him
Jesus we tried
what are you talking about what does
that mean we tried we wanted John Paul
dead Gracie
we were doing it for you
we wanted to save you
we wanted you and blana to be free
Gracie